the Chinese missile frigate yang Chang
arrived in Cyprus from here it's only
250 kilometers to the Syrian port city
of Latakia where the chemical weapons
will be shipped from a large contingent
from the local Chinese community turned
out in the port of Limassol to welcome
the vessel many here say they're proud
that their country is part of this
high-profile international mission China
support the efforts of international
community to destroy the Syrian chemical
weapons and we come to Cyprus and
participated in this international
operation the Chinese warship will
protect the Scandinavian convoy
responsible for carrying the chemical
weapons out of Syria the seven hundred
ton toxic cargo will then be transferred
to the US Cape ray which is currently
docked in Virginia it's equipped with
special treatment units that are capable
of neutralizing deadly toxins at high
sea
poor ground you can see our buffer
storage egg that's where agent is it's
basically held immediately behind that
is the hydrolysis skin that's where the
chemical reaction is started the
destruction will take place at an
undisclosed location in the
Mediterranean it's the first time the
neutralizing technology will be used
offshore the International crews are
still waiting for the go-ahead but it
could still take days before that
happens and a lot could still go wrong
the biggest challenge transporting the
chemical weapons through war-torn Syria
to the coast